he says it's a russian military vessel
near to a commercial ship
[Music]
the young officer he's only 23
immediately takes extra care to be sure
his presence isn't mistakenly seen as a
provocation
the sea of azov is a unique flashpoint
in tensions between moscow and kiev
both countries supposedly share these
waves but russia is accused of
restricting ukraine's access and
threatening its ships
on the maritime front line
the junior officer describes how things
can get tense
up
russia's navy is accused of blocking off
sections of the sea for non-existent
military exercises
forcing ukrainian boats to steer clear
or using jamming devices to mess with
their communications
we're told that russian patrol boats
constantly follow ukrainian ships and
vessels leaving this port it's a
provocation that the ukrainians say
they're careful to avoid doing in return
ukraine's navy only has a few ships left
since russia annexed crimea in 2014
where most of them were based
they're busy rebuilding with financing
support from the uk
including to turn this space in the
southeastern city of berdyansk into a
much bigger one but the threat of
another russian invasion is now and the
deputy head of the navy signaled it
could come from the sea
when they might just never succeed
a threat his sailors seem determined to
resist
debra haynes sky news in the sea of azov